معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي امين نريد ان نعرف اكثر حول اجتماع
لابيد نتنياهو دوافعه الحقيقيه كذلك وال
الاصداء
بخصوصه نعم هذا الاجتماع جاء
كحاطب حسب القانون
الاسرائيلي تجرى بين رئيس الحكومه وزعيم
المعارضه واتفق اي لابيد ونتن على ان تكون
هذه الاحاطه الامنيه في المرحله المقبله
اسبوعيه خلال هذا الاجتماع طبعا تم
التركيز على صفقه تبادل الاسرى من
خلال التصريحات التي ادلى بها لابيد بدا
من جديد على انه متمسك ومصر على ان
المرحله المقبله تقتضي في الدرجه الاولى
تركيز على مساله استعاده المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين وايضا انجاح صفقه تبادل
الاسرى لابيد الذي طبعا في الاونه الاخيره
لطالما
انتقد المعسكر المقابل اي نتنياهو و وزراء
اليمين المتطرف الذين يؤكدون على استمرار
الحرب والتركيز على رفض سحب القوات
الاسرائيليه من قطاع غزه اضافه الى رفض
اطلاق سراح عدد كبير من
الاسرى الاسرائيليين هذا الجدل الذي كان
قد او كانت الحكومه الاسرائيليه وال
الاوساط السياسيه بشكل عام قد شهدته في
الفتره الاخيره يمكن القول بانه انقسام
حول صفقه الاسرى اليوم نتنياهو يؤكد من
جديد على ان الحرب مستمره وعلى انه لن
يقبل بالشروط التي تقدمت بها حركه حماس و
في المقابل طبعا يؤكد بان الحل العسكري هو
الذي سيوصل في نهايه المطاف الى امكانيه
استعاده المحتجزين والاسرى الاسرائيليين
في قطاع غزه لكن يلحظ من خلال ايضا
التصريحات التي ادلى بها اليوم وزير
الدفاع
جالانت بشان استمرار الحرب و تواصل الضغط
العسكري الاسرائيلي على حركه
حماس يلحظ ان هناك تناقض في الحقيقه بين
موقفه وموقف رئيس الحكومه من ناحيه انه
طالب حركه حماس جالانت بضروره ارسال ردها
على الشروط
وال الاطار العام المتعلق بصفقه تبادل
الاسرى فيما نتنياهو يؤكد على ان هذه
الشروط هي مرفوضه وهذا التناقض راى فيه
كثيرين على انه عدم تنسيق بين الجانبين في
هذا الخصوص طبعا هناك ضغوط داخليه ايضا من
قبل
اهالي المحتجزين والاسرى الاسرائيليين من
خ خلال الوقفات التضامنيه من خلال ايضا
محاولات عدد من اهالي هؤلاء الاسرى اليوم
الدخول الى الكنيست الى مبنى الكنيست
الاسرائيلي وتم منعهم عن طريق عدد من
النواب التابعين لحزب الليكود الذي يتزعمه
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو هناك ايضا
ضغوط خارجيه كشفت عنها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اليوم وسيله وتتمثل هذه الضغوط
في سعي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ل
ارغام نتنياهو على القبول بصفقه قد تمتد
لاكثر من اربعه اشهر صفقه تبادل للاسرى
وايضا وقف اطلاق النار عبر مرحلتين لكن
تبقى الاشكاليه بحسب هذه المعلومات في
المرحله الثانيه التي تقتضي من اسرائيل
وقف العمليات العسكريه بشكل كامل وايضا
اطلاق سراح اسماء وازنه من الاسرى
الفلسطين مقابل اطلاق عسكريين اسرى جنود
اسرائيليين لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه بينما
تقتصر المرحله الاولى التي من المرتقب ان
تستمر ل 35 يوما عدد من الاسرى من النساء
وايضا المرضى والاطفال والشيوخ وخمس
مجندات هناك جدل كبير بشان كل هذه النقاط
عشيه طبعا وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن عشيه
ايضا عدد من التصريحات التي كنا قد
سمعناها على لسان وزير الامن القومي
ايتمار بن كفير الذي اتهم بايدن بادخال
المساعدات والتركيز على دعم حماس مقابل
التخلي او التراجع عن تقديم الدعم
لاسرائيل هذه التصريحات والاتهامات ايضا
التي خلقت زوبعه من وطوفان من ردود
والانتقادات داخل اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك
امين درغامي مراسلنا من
ت